les rapports alarmistes succèdent aux
marches pour le climat et pourtant
l'écologie n'a jamais vraiment infuser
dans cette campagne présidentielle en
témoigne ce baromètre du climat le thème
n'a occupé que 4 % du temps de parole
dans les débats et vous qu'en pensez
vous l'avenir de la planète est il
suffisamment abordé dans cette élection
voyez ce reportage à tour et près de
richelieu d'hélène chapelet avec
théodore de queiros
elle travaille en lien avec les animaux
et la nature magali est agricultrice bio
à kourou et l élève notamment des ports
en plein air ça ferme elle l'a voulu à
taille humaine tout ce qu'elle produit
est d'ailleurs vendu par ses soins en
circuit court via son propre magasin la
biodiversité la sauvegarde des zones
humides le bien-être animal ou encore la
lutte contre les pesticides sont des
thèmes qui lui sont chers mais qu'elle
ne retrouve pas forcément dans le
programme des candidats au second tour
de la présidentielle
on peut parler de la disparition des
petits oiseaux des insectes
donc pour nous on agriculture biologique
c'est c1 c'est c'est très important en
fait et oui on se dit des fois qu'on va
dans le mur mais qu' on tient bon c'est
comme dans notre assiette on a besoin de
diversité et à force de
de simplifier notre assiette on tombe
malade à force de simplifier nos
paysages et ben la nature à tant de
malades personnellement je fais partie
de ces gens qui ne se reconnaissent dans
quasiment aujourd'hui aucun parti
la nature et plus généralement la
planète serait-elle la grande oubliée de
ce second tour qu'en pensent les
citadins tourangeau je suis extrêmement
catastrophé il n'ya pas d'autre mot par
les perspectives qui nous attendent en
termes d'écologie comme en termes
d'économies comme maman en termes de vie
sociale l'écologie c'est pas quelque
chose ouais voilà c'est pas notre
priorité c'est vraiment le bien-être de
votre famille oui voilà notre petit il
parle plus de réchauffement climatique
mais il suit qui se passe dans un
objectif clair et précis part je trouve
qu'on a suffisamment parlé pendant le
premier tour et aujourd'hui ma
préoccupation majeure comme une majorité
des français c'est toutefois d'achat le
futur gouvernement ne pourra pas faire
comme s'il ne savait pas dans le dernier
rapport du giec les experts du climat
ont listé les préconisations pour
limiter le réchauffement climatique
l'industrie les transports l'agriculture
ou le bâtiment devrait revoir leurs
pratiques si l'on veut parvenir à
limiter les dégâts